[Music]
like most kids i really loved
superheroes and comic books superman was
one of my favorites i so enjoyed those
movies but i don't think i enjoyed them
nearly as much as christian my brother
did so much so that he watched the movie
superman 3
so often that he wore a hole in the vhs
tapes we're aging ourselves
it was first grade and i watched
superman 3 every single day after school
i was so obsessed with that i would wear
a superman outfit as a little kid and
put my clark kent white button-down
shirt on top of my glasses and i would
walk around my house and when i found
someone i would perform this transition
from clark kent to superman but instead
of i couldn't rip open my white
button-down shirt so i had to very
quickly unbutton all the buttons
and and open it and obviously i grew up
to be much more of a clark kent than a
superman which is you know pretty big
understatement it depends on what you
value but i still feel like i have that
seven-year-old superman inside of me
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Applause]
[Music]
and i'm with another long a younger long
christian so the story that christian
just mentioned um story can you call it
a story the
anecdote yeah that lasted for about a
year that phase i would say and only
because the tape broke it could only
last as long as that vhs lasted that's
true and the best part was why i
remember my parents having to
wait for your shirt to come off and be
like oh what's gonna happen you know
they were really good about that i
remember singing the theme song as i did
it i was like and i was like
and i would and i would have to keep
looping that that that melody because i
couldn't get my shirt off that time
they're like tympani introduced
i always had really puffy hair and i was
insecure about that so i i would water
it down so it was close to my head and i
would make a little
curl remember he had that little on his
forehead yeah that little curl of hair
like a little forehead pube
and i would shape it into a little curl
i remember and i felt so cool but we
recently re-watched that movie and
i think it holds up i do too richard
pryor is amazing so good he's so funny
and
as clark kent and superman uh
christopher reeve was just the best was
so earnest
and funny and every time how difficult
that is to do to play both of those
parts equally well to be convincingly
bumbling and awkward and then to be this
to be superman it's a feat and they
looked exactly like yeah it's a little
for the outfit and the fact that no one
ever yeah looking back on it now that
part doesn't age as well no especially
when they're in smallville because it's
such a small town and you think like
obviously superman he's got to be the
most famous person definitely in the
town if not the world so you'd think if
someone who looked like this most famous
person in town
showed up same body big muscles gorgeous
face just covered up with glasses
and a white button-down shirt you'd
think at some point someone would be
like
wait a minute at least lana lang lana
lang who knew clark kent really well i
mean knew him intimately would be like
hold on a second wait can you just put
these glasses on for a second i just
want to see something
um anyway speaking of superman our guest
today is a superhero himself yeah jeremy
renner and he jeremy renner now knows
what it must feel like to be on the
receiving end of
somebody's adulation like a kid's
adulation like like the like little
version of me exactly um he must he must
feel that from
all these kids all these fans who look
up to him so much and
that must be a
a huge
responsibility for him yeah i would
think yeah jeremy is an actual superhero
and as you'll all hear he shares many
similar traits as a superhero
i met him about
15 years ago probably a little after you
did and i i remember i met him at a
karaoke bar he was
in a big group of people we were we're
there with a bunch of friends and he
he was quiet and kind of kept to himself
and at one point he got up to sing for
the first time and
this is not hyperbole
he is the greatest to this day the
greatest karaoke singer i've ever heard
in my life he's saying
bohemian rhapsody and it
melted my face yeah it was so good it
was i remember i it's a karaoke
performance we were all drinking and i
still remember it i still remember
what it looked like what it sounded like
i i'm saying karaoke with real singers
they don't compare and you know since
then obviously in the last 10 years
especially he's gone from karaoke singer
in a bar to being one of the biggest
movie stars on the planet wouldn't you
say yeah i remember the time thinking i
was sort of surprised that he was
pursuing acting i thought why why would
this guy not be just he's a singer he's
incredible he's the best i've i've heard
we were all blown away by it
so i did not know him as an actor i knew
him as
a friend of a friend and this guy who
was like had an incredible voice so when
this did happen to him which
was probably about a year later right
i'm going to put a picture of him
singing karaoke on instagram but
it came as a surprise to me i didn't
i don't think i'd seen him in anything
up until then and now of course i've
seen him in many things
but it's happened yeah over the last 10
years and if you're one of the handful
of people who hasn't seen any of the
avengers movies
then
you might also know him from mission
impossible franchise the bourne
franchise he does really huge cool
movies he was in the town he was
nominated for an oscar for that so now
good news about his singing voice he's
now about to be a musician that people
can hear he's recording music he has an
animated movie coming out november a
kids movie that he does the whole
soundtrack for he sings the whole
soundtrack for you guys are in for a
treat your ears are gonna melt like ours
did 10 years ago and hopefully your ears
will also enjoy my chat with mr jeremy
renner coming up next
in the last 10 years
things have
really happened in a way that you i'm
guessing
you've always wanted i mean i i guess
you're living the life that most actors
want is does it feel that way do you
feel fulfilled i mean it's hard to
really kind of quantify yeah you know
where it's at at this moment with you
know end game just being out well i
should also say that before i knew you
as an actor i knew you
as one of the most talented singers i've
ever heard
i thought i was when i said
when we hung out one night i saw you
give a karaoke performance that was
better than anyone i'd ever seen in my
life and i remember thinking like why is
this guy an actor you should be like
you should be playing the phantom the
opera or something you should be a rock
star uh
you sang um bohemian rhapsody oh yeah
yeah was that your go-to no no i i i
mean i
sang yeah karaoke for like 10 years man
um
uh being in l.a just being a broke-ass
actor and it's the only thing i could
afford to do because it's free oh yeah
and heck i'd even get a free drink once
in a while and maybe a taco
that i couldn't afford so you just
perfected singing you because i always
loved doing it it was i always loved
singing singing and or writing music and
being in music was something i did well
before acting but i
i never wanted to do it as a job so it
was a great fun way for me to kind of
sing have fun and um
it was a social scene every day
i know in my life to this moment we
pretty much met in the karaoke bar oh
really what was i playing gower gulch
gary goldstein there's barney's beanery
where he five places we'd rotate to and
wow i mean almost for a decade we go at
least four times a week oh really
because it was like our social life as
well you know who so who's in this crew
do i know these guys um i met a guy
walter hey walter essenavia who uh i
actually songwrite with now oh so you
are doing music yeah yeah there's two
songs that i already had written that's
that are in this kid's animated movie
where i did the lead voice on that comes
out in november called arctic dogs so we
did the whole soundtrack for that movie
which was cool mix i did that last year
and then arctic dogs arctic dogs and
that comes out um in
november 1st
and so
from that point on we kept writing a ton
more music and then uh now it's all
starting to come out so like the
floodgates open so you it's opened up
now yeah that's great big time opened up
now but just nobody knows that i've i'm
doing it quite yet so now it's all being
released
exactly and so it's all being released
uh almost as we speak so this is
something you've been doing for a while
you you mentioned uh maybe in the part
we didn't record that uh that you had
never intended to do it as a career you
never music was just something you loved
yeah yeah music is something i did when
i was a kid and um a garage band and
playing drums and just learned
by playing yeah and then i wanted to
song write so then i watched people
um
play piano on break in school you're
like seem to be like a true renaissance
man like like the house flipping stuff
you you right you know how to build
things you for a long time that hustle
um
allowed you to do a lot of other things
which you you continue to do yeah was
that just a means to survive
well it was you know like not having
very much money
i didn't like paying rent because it
just didn't make financial sense i
didn't have any money really but so at
some point
um
who's really more like my brother at
this point um is a christopher we we
decided to pool our little bit of money
we got together instead of get like a a
condo in the valley like let's go get
this house and we and we fixed it up a
little bit they didn't intend to sell it
but then
the realtor came in after we were done
she's like you know we can sell it for
this price like what we never heard of
that much money in our lives
and then we just kept going and learning
as as we went as well i feel like with
everything in life yeah i just kind of
have i'm a kind of an actionable person
and i learned by doing yeah and by
failing and and just kept going and i
always knew that this is my the biggest
investment in my life for anyone's life
really but it's a roof over your head
it's a tangible thing it's not a
you're not investing in a stock or a
bond or something you're investing in a
home or a lifestyle yeah and then we
both just got better and got really good
at it and that also allowed so you kind
of taught yourselves yeah absolutely
absolutely and it allowed it allowed me
financially to
really have confidence going into in the
audition room uh with the kind of big
brass ball saying i don't need this job
you don't need it that's huge yeah if
you can go in not needing a job yeah
it's so much of acting i uh
strikes me as just being confident as i
think so getting out of your own way
yeah
yeah but so at the time when you're
doing this house flipping acting is
something that you that was a passion
that you didn't have it as a kid i
didn't realize no you you fell into it
kind of later yeah yeah
how did that happen college um i always
went to school local jc just to get the
undergrad out of the way and then i
figured i was gonna go somewhere i
didn't know i was taking computer
science i was didn't know what the heck
i wanted to do and then stumbled on a
it's an elective an acting class that's
crazy that my dad sort of encouraged me
just like just take this give me like
the you know math and certain things
that were transferable like nine new
units or something he said whatever
after that just try stuff go fail son
just try things and then i tried this
acting class the only thing i remember
about signing up for that elective is
like what the hell i know about acting
or what that is i just remember kirk
cameron and family you know
uh growing pains growing pains and then
family ties was not j5 exactly i'm like
oh that's what i knew about acting oh my
god
well you're not wrong
and then it's kind of i guess so anyone
listening that's kind of all you need to
know that's right and you'll be uh in an
adventure that's right
so what so when you're in that class are
you like you're just kind of doing it to
do something different and then at one
point are you like oh [ __ ] this is
clicked pretty quickly yeah you know if
you know as an actor it's like what that
when you do a play or it's
there's a you know they always say you
get bit by the bug or what type of thing
but yeah what that really means is i i
think there's a wonderful
communion communion that happens and
it's you play make-believe you revert
back to being the purest form of
ourselves where things are like five
years old when you have no fear and
you're encouraged to
to make believe and play yeah yeah i'm
now doing it to 48 you know so you're so
lucky they make believe yeah i know like
you can you've and and you have a first
hand like uh you can witness a
six-year-old did you have a daughter
that's right yeah i just left her yeah
well thanks
sorry she's like who daddy who are you
gonna go talk to what's a podcast i'll
be right back
like oh this guy i'm
friends with guilty never mind i'll be
back
what is she like what is it it must be
cool to see
i mean that form of you must be a great
dad because you're so good at playing i
mean you're a professional i'd say it's
the best role to date i've had and will
always be is being a daddy yeah it's the
best thing it's it's directed but
everything
uh yeah
there's a reward but no award yeah
the reward is you know getting woke up
to her her little face this morning yeah
you know it starts off my day great yeah
and then i see yours yeah
it's all downhill from there
well then you get to get to go back to
work i'm really happy to see you yeah me
too man we used to have so much fun and
uh yeah god i'm telling you it's it's
the the last
since we've seen each other the changes
have been monumental i mean
as big as they can be for an actor
what was the point where you felt like
okay now this is this is going to be
happening from now on this is like i
don't have to go but i don't have to
rely on anything else to survive or to
get by i think that but that to me
happened when i on my first job
my first job ever and that's when it
kind of
like okay cool it was a domino
no this is like senior trip in 1993 94 i
think oh wow
you know that's when i feel like okay
i'm working as an actor my first job
ever was not a
guest star in something or an extra
lead of a national lampoon movie oh [ __ ]
so not that it was great or anything but
it was just i don't know i i was always
encouraged along the way and i got
enough work to feel like i didn't have
to
do any bar job or waiting tables or any
of those times you were a makeup artist
as a makeup artist yeah that was a that
that uh
freed up my week to audition all week
but
i always i've always felt like
this is what i'm doing and this is what
i'm down here for and i was very focused
on that so again you didn't feel the
pressure you didn't feel like ah any
fear i mean maybe no no i've been pretty
good about working on fear yeah uh
that's something i also did in college
as a young man i studied theater and
psychology
and
knowing that fear is the most powerful
human emotion sadly i wish it was love
fear can stop a lot of things and force
people into bad decisions or decisions
they didn't really choose to do or want
to do
are there moments where you you felt
that fear got in the way you look back
on you with me i i knew when it would
stop me from things in life yeah and i
was very conscious of those things so i
worked on something i was afraid of
every day for a decade
and realized after 10 years that all
those things from this could be
fear of sharks fear of intimacy fear of
success
a lot of different types of fear right
yeah and all that what they had in all
in common is just the unknown yeah the
unknown is what we typically are afraid
of yeah and when you become educated
about it then you're not so afraid of it
are do any linger do you have any like
remedies
what about success i mean
i think that came suddenly that that
real big success yeah i know what to say
even my eye for my perspective success
was
um i never wanted fame right i just i
was just good at my job what i love to
do and i became famous for those things
right yeah there are some people that
want to be famous
uh i don't hang around those people
[Laughter]
those are all my friends yeah exactly
but that you know just kind of came with
with the thing yeah but uh yeah i think
from my perspective it's it's been such
a slow trajectory from 93 up until now
in 2019 of of success and there's
milestones like
hurt locker and other things befriending
me exactly yeah yeah
but but like you say you don't want fame
but fame is now an obvious byproduct of
how good you've been as an actor so what
how do you deal with that then that is a
that is a new thing relatively new in
the last 10 years yeah how
how were you how did you adjust to that
um and are you still ingesting uh it's
it's
i stay i stay home a lot more
um yeah like it just because end game
came out right here now
i remember being at barney's beanery
yeah in 1999 or something i did like
some bud light campaign or something or
something whatever what yeah it's right
now you look familiar look like somebody
went to high school with uh-huh and then
it went to oh wait yeah you're the guy
in that thing and then tell me where i
know you're from and now
fifth graders know my first and last
name that's crazy when i dropped my
daughter off at school that's jeremy
renner and they got cell phones they
want selfies i'm like i'm out of here
how does your daughter handle that what
does she think of that that's that's
didn't happen when
i dropped off in her class already and i
came out and
i yeah i got you know but first of all
if you're going to get attacked by like
30 people let it be fourth of july it's
probably because you're damn cute dude
and i'll do anything for kids get away
from me
he doesn't even carry a bow and arrow
but yeah that must feel cool like kids
yeah the kids part of it is is kind of
the
amazing amazing thing and this is like a
kind of global across the globe kind of
thing and knowing that they they really
make my day better when that happens you
know yeah because i do love kids so much
it's they maybe some of the adults
yeah the older the older kids yeah the
all the kids with the sweaty palms
that's right and you know wanting a
selfie at the urinal yeah come on man
i know it's for my son yeah well then
angle up a little bit yeah i see where
you're playing um yeah my friend happens
so you're working for a while dahmer is
like you mentioned as like a milestone
yeah um yeah big time how did that how
did you get that how did that come about
yeah that's it's a really strange uh
experience uh i remember seeing you on a
show called the it factor yeah you were
on that it was a reality type show yeah
yeah that was after dahmer you had shot
it yeah i remember that was mentioned on
the show a few times yeah like i'm
waiting for this to come out i mean i
got this script i didn't know who
jeffrey dahmer was
and sat with the director the next day
the next day we were filming and then 13
days later we were done filming what
yeah weird i'm like i don't know what
the heck i was doing
i had to it's a strangest experience the
strangest degree was shot you know on
short ends on film
which just means you only have like 30
seconds to a minute and a half of takes
to do and it was just a guerrilla
filmmaking shorthand was before digital
they would have they would get scrap
space yeah yeah you can't yeah exactly
because they're cans of film you know
they're a thousand feet wherever these
are like 100 feet which is like
literally a minute
oh my god yeah it's just how we did it
and how it happened i have no idea where
you know i'm gonna go back and rewatch
that no no idea so they couldn't do long
takes they couldn't do any any
tracking shots right wow wow uh
so you had literally a day to research
that yeah yeah it was good i didn't know
much about him uh because then i'd
probably come with judgment or something
like that would be hard to do if he had
a lot of you know hatred or anger or
something
yeah judgment that comes with that so i
mean i knew kind of something but not
really much detail and like because that
i had to approach it from a kind of a
different more
more so maybe yeah more understanding
yeah yeah uh
and and so and that led then to
certainly the in people in the industry
knowing yeah you know being on their
radar and
i'm sure that's how i met my uh agent
actually because the trailer of domino
was playing before eisens
ivan's ecstasy and then he saw the
trailer and then
called did you think after dahmer and
you get the agent
at that point are you thinking this is
going to be my big break this is no i no
no no no i had it was weird because like
like i said after shooting it i woke up
i had no electricity in my apartment
uh-huh i remember waking up
and i didn't have to go to work that day
and like wow did we just do a whole
movie that's nuts did i did did i just
play as a serial killer
did that just no idea i had no idea what
really transpired or how it would be or
do you do are you like that usually you
lose yourself in the with that one that
one in particular immersion i had to
kind of stay in it yeah you know because
it's it's it's far stretch for me man
it's a very fast stretch and it's very
oh i wouldn't think
um yeah so i i had i was pretty much
always on camera and always kind of just
in it because it's a really weird place
to be her locker must have changed that
did change things radically but again is
that the same kind of thing where you're
not
you strike me as someone who's not
conscientious of how this will affect
this never yeah yeah no no never forward
yeah huh it's just being present doing
the job yeah where did you do that job
that was in morocco that was in jordan
difficulty strikes a lot of sand a lot
of that was uh
yeah yeah there was a lot of sand at the
end of the day a lot of sand sandwiches
man yeah that was uh very very it was
very difficult because 135 degrees in
the underground bomb suit but that was
the easy part
it was pretty amazing but i never want
to do it again yeah i died yeah glad you
did it rewarding yeah yeah yeah but then
when we were done with that movie we
were like
i don't know is this going to suck is
this going to be anything is it even
going to be a film is it a is this a
series we had no idea well because so
much of it is
visual are you diffusing the tension so
much of the tension a lot of the movie
too you don't you never we never saw you
know catherine that you didn't know what
the set was the sets were giant it's
like a square mile in the middle of the
middle east you have no idea who's in
the movie or not in the movie right you
the the cameras were on long lenses and
always moving you never saw any so i
hadn't like i think are they filming i
hope they're getting this yeah new idea
but everyone saw when you'd see barry
akroyd come around he'd pop out of a
trunk
like that he would he would he said he
was the one that would come close and i
knew there was actually film being shot
oh my god um otherwise like
what's happening you know oh the days
catherine's like okay there's a
ied 300 meters down down this road okay
let's go i mean our whole day was to go
do that
so we just had no there's no strange it
was really strange so are you
improvising that stuff
yeah there's a lot of stuff that's
improvised there's a lot
yeah i mean it was more real than it
really needed to be yeah yeah
so she was going for a very like cinema
verite like a real like capturing yeah
very much so like that i didn't know
ultimately what we're looking at i never
saw
uh any dailies or you know playback
because there was no playback she had
four clam shelters these tiny little
screens to see what was going on oh my
god we were just going so can you
so then was it a surprise when
all this thing this stuff happened yeah
that thing really
started taking off uh a lot yeah um like
awards wise and all that yeah
yeah a lot a lot of attention came came
and came with that
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
you start doing these huge movies the uh
mission
yeah although that happened pretty quick
around the hurt locker i don't want to
say this do you enjoy
those bigger things there's a lot more
time a downtime a lot more waiting
around you enjoying bigger movies yeah
how do you busy yourself there's yeah i
feel like for the big movies i've been
um i've been able to do and been blessed
to do there's there's still really great
character within
them all otherwise i wouldn't have done
it yeah it's not just
running around and
whatever but there's some sort of depth
to the character so i've always found
some sort of
just gratifying in a way and then
there's also certain challenges because
a lot of them were action films and i
had to learn and i learned from tom
cruise that you have to
prepare your body to
for a beating if you will to
repeat over and over and over again
right stunts and then nobody's better
and it's yeah so i really learned that
you know it's it's it's like a sport
it's like a it's like you have to be an
athlete right were you an athletic kid
yeah very much really so that's what i
really kind of clung to you know i've
been learning new skill sets that i
would never learn like kalei and um only
some judo throws and all these all these
things
and uh so you know
i love that i love that so much so that
was um i was always always in the gym
always having to train and learn and do
something new and fine and that i found
a lot of um there wasn't a lot of down
time because of course i wasn't just
sitting around being bored also what
you're putting in your body i mean a lot
of it is nutritional too you have to be
aware of everything yeah i think the
last time i saw you you were in the
midst of something like that and you
were like god i'm i'm having to watch
everything i eat and going out and um
yeah do you want to continue
musically do you want to stay aw
music is really kind of become more
uh
serious to me in a way because i just
recorded started recording like three
years ago and that was new
and since i've been recording
it's just been a lot of fun and the same
kind of fulfilling as acting even more
so probably more because i can do it so
quickly yeah yeah i don't have for the
even the end result or the writing
process um
is more gratifying and also i can just
sit down on a piano and sing
i don't need a camera purely script i
don't have to go anywhere most
importantly yeah and um it's still
emotionally expressive and
certain challenges within it and that uh
i can do it in my home yeah and my
daughter with my daughter yeah and
movies take me away to tom cruise to
botswana for nine months and like that
doesn't really serve me when you're a
father when you're overseas does she
come is she able to come and see you
over there i've been i've she was too
young
to fly her that far yeah and still at
this age i wouldn't fly her that far i'd
fly home every other weekend oh wow and
i was living in um london doing
mission impossible and then avenger
age of ultron back to back i used to fly
home from london to l.a every other
weekend it was pretty brutal
this is why i just had to
re-shift
things for my life you know and so it
worked for my me and my daughter yeah
yeah and probably that means being a lot
more selective that means uh or just
yeah it's in this i've always been
pretty selective it's just um even when
i i was broke or whatever yeah uh
but it's it just has to be serve me
being in front of my daughter otherwise
it i just it's just not even considered
i mean in terms of feeling that way
about another human being that you never
met would did that just
knock you over it was that
in a wonderful way yeah
when you know when you're so clear about
what you want uh-huh and also you know
what you don't want it's life is is a
lot easier yeah life is a lot easier
when you were make a part you're how
long were you a makeup artist for
uh i didn't wanna do that for like eight
years i believe eight years yeah do you
and you so you worked with a lot of
actors
no no i did these i did i worked uh i
avoided
i didn't want to work uh
i was down here to be an actor so i
never worked
in the film side of makeup i was working
at malls doing like
um
teaching people how to apply makeup at a
lancome counter or laura mercier or
whatever it might have been you know do
you you must have
any funny stories
so many so many it gives me one strange
odd oh my god experiences over those
so you're the guy that it's usually it's
it's women who are like correct hey do
you want to buy this thing yeah they do
little tutorials yeah did women
were they ever
uh hesitant to go sit at your thing
because you're
i don't know i don't know they may or
may not have been but it was it was
always it was much more of a therapy
session sitting down
and because i was a terrible salesman i
could not sell anything
but but why things were bought um is
because i sat with them and asked them
you know how much time do you spend
putting on makeup and why what do you
know what colors you like you know just
asking parents about them and can direct
it into
how do i make this woman feel beautiful
it has nothing to do with makeup
because that's where the beauty comes in
right the beauty is how you feel about
yourself and then it's projected out
if you feel insecure you feel empty or
you you don't feel good about yourself
it's just i don't care what makeup i put
on you it might look beautiful but
you're not beautiful so i'm gonna try to
find a way in to make them feel
beautiful
and then this is how we output it with
makeup or
anything else was that something that
that you just came naturally did
something this is a natural thing right
because
i've always been very very interested in
human behavior again with psychology
background and then applying that every
day as an actor
in work um which is human behavior so i
became really really
um great and aware of human behavior
very perceptive very much so
what do you remember any in particular
that you could you can talk about that
that were well well one there's this
interesting story but it was much more
kind of thoughtful and amazing these two
gals came up one you know had a lot more
uh makeup and the other ones you know
looks like she probably never wears
makeup and dada anyway they both sat
down had a great little five-minute
conversation and put some makeup on and
made him feel good and then off they
skipped
they came back and there's some guy
hands me a card or they handed me a card
i can't remember
and
i got offered to go be a makeup artist
for playboy
i'm listening and yeah i'm listening i
want lotion
and you know
we're going to take a pause now
so i got offered to go to put makeup on
beautiful women and i'm like wow it
sounds like a dream job but i'm going to
have to pass because i just know that's
just not where i want to go in life and
it would lead me away from my directive
coming down to la to be an actor so i
had
to pass on that job what ha oh you would
have had to leave la no no be here but
it's a full-time job oh full-time job
like no no no i can't do that i never
did anything for money so the two women
that that sat that you
knew the guy or whatever and pretty much
yeah and then so i called afterwards to
cut the story short you know got the
card and then called them down they
wanted me just to be yeah i had to to do
it
and i say no i can't do it and uh oh wow
um
was that hard are those the moments hard
for you really like no no because you're
already making money without question
it's
never never doing anything for money
um
that that gave me the big brass balls in
any decision i made because i know it
wasn't ever about money and it probably
helps growing up without a lot of money
because it wasn't like you had this bar
that had been set like you got a lit you
need a portion you need these things
yeah yeah you weren't exposed to that as
a kid
uh
that's gotta help a lot yeah yeah i mean
i was you know eating in five dollars a
month and yeah he's back against the
wall and living with no power that kind
of stuff is which is pretty tough but
at least i know that i can say no like
it happened with guillermo de toro
who uh very very amazing director yeah
but uh hellboy was a movie
that they they offered me was a lot of
money that i've ever heard in my life
but i still had to say no because i
didn't have any
didn't have i didn't know a way into the
character in that movie and that was
before that was before
took off that was after dahmer oh my god
before swat that's balls and i had to
say it was like quarter million dollars
and i had no electricity like
candlelight right and it's crazy it
could it never crossed my brain that oh
that'd be great to have that money i was
just reading this script i'm like i
don't get this it's
kind of the comic thing and there was
like a detective in it i just couldn't
connect to it so i said i i can't find a
way in i don't know what i would be
doing um so i had to say no that's nuts
i mean i've heard
sammy's mentioned that about you and
that you he's has his own stories and
that i just can't forget the money like
i would think and also the opportunity
of being a big movie yeah it's just just
you know wow it's got it's got a i got
to feel like i can contribute something
and then with confidence if i i didn't
have confidence in i didn't know it was
just like it's one thing to not know and
go learn something but there's one thing
where you just
there's nothing you don't see anything
you can contribute i feel like you're
shopping down the wrong aisle you know
yeah i'm not uh
not to that degree but i occasionally
get offered these things where i and i
and i always try to place myself two
weeks in you know it's that two-week
mark where you're like because i've
taken too many jobs where two weeks in
i'm sitting in a hotel room in
in georgia and i'm like what what am i
doing this is not fun it's not
fulfilling and it's i try to place
myself too because my instinct is always
guys
yeah oh my god they're gonna pay me
to do a movie i don't care i'm probably
short fine he's fine
i'll do it uh yeah but it's the two
weeks in it's like time is you know
precious and the older you get it's like
the
more precious it becomes uh
was the director i remember jonah hill
passing on
transformers when we were he
and i remember thinking this before
super bad came out and all this stuff i
remember thinking
are you nuts this is a movie people are
gonna see it's do you when you make a
decision like that to you and he was
same thing just total confidence like
i'm
he didn't didn't seem strike me as as
somebody who would second guess do you
did you do you ever think back um a
couple weeks afterwards you still have
no electricity or you're struggling to
pay bills and you think ah [ __ ] this
could be a lot easier yeah i regret that
no there's zero growth wow zero wow wow
zeros most times like ooh i'm glad i
didn't do it yeah it made sense to me
uh-huh especially when you see it not
just a hellboy or whatever it was and
and i'm not saying that's good or a bad
movie it's not about that yeah i'm just
glad i understand that it wouldn't fit
in that it wouldn't fit there was there
a moment with the marvel when they came
to you with marvel with hawkeye
was there a moment where you had to kind
of figure out a way in or was that a
pretty clear way that was pretty easy
even though i didn't know much about you
know the comics or any of that kind of
world the only thing that was out at the
time was iron man um and i i love that
and i think they're about to go make
thor
and i sat down with kevin feige
and i said hey man what you guys did
with iron man it's actually almost kind
of plausible that's why i buy it it's
amazing that down he's tremendous and
yeah
i'm like in the sense of humor and all
that sort of stuff and then how are you
gonna do this with like you know fabio
flying around with a hammer i i don't
get how this is gonna happen at the time
and then you got you know hemsworth they
just pulled this off and made it so
killer and uh and then that's when they
showed me my character i'm like oh
that's great it's just a guy with a with
no superpower
he's just got a high skill set i mean oh
great i can actually
attach to that yeah yeah yeah i would
have released on thor all day long not
that i'd ever be cast in that but like
that kind of thing i've been like i
don't know how to do that i'm sorry
but like hawkeye or clint barton i'm
like oh great my skill set i can do i
can figure that out you see a way in
yeah and and has it been rewarding
playing that character
uh yeah yeah for sure for sure um
it's it's there's good
yeah
yeah there's gonna be
there's always some more this can be
great oh yeah oh yeah okay we can't yeah
yeah i can't say anything don't reveal
anything exciting on this show
we like to keep it mundane stories that
people already know yeah um it'd be
great if you could retread that uh
so do you ever think about writing or
drag you're so you're bright you know
no way man that takes weight like you
said time yeah you know it's you know
it's like three to six months for an
actor on a set but think about all the
prep and then the post yeah especially
now as a father a single father there's
no way man i mean i love the idea of it
um but there's no way i could the
practicality of time is um not not going
to happen so you might direct something
what is um
are there are there performances you
look back on and and you're more proud
of than others are there ones this might
be impossible questions are are there
ones that you do you have any regrets
about any of the
roles you've done you think now god if i
had the opportunities now i wouldn't
have done
such or does it yeah
well i think they're all they've all
informed yeah me
of things and um
i've enjoyed it everything i've done and
do you think about how you're perceived
do you ever think about perception
legacy no i give zero [ __ ] yeah about
perception i i knew that but i wanted
you to say it
you just wanted me to say yeah i was
just setting you up this is my face we
needed more zero yeah it's true i i was
i i knew you before all this crazy [ __ ]
happened and and
eddie always struck me as somebody who
gave zero bucks and if it's possible to
get less than zero [ __ ] it's also like
my wrestling face yeah you have a zero
it's a very angry resting face at least
my mom's is and i got it from hers but
it i pretty much built a career upon it
and a belief system
yeah i have the opposite kind of face uh
what what the happy inviting yeah hey
take advantage of me take advantage of
me
eager but i'm really dark exactly
wait what did your mom do again you said
my mom she was a bookkeeper bookkeeper
yeah and and are you still close with
all your siblings yeah they're well
they're currently living in my house
you're too close for them yeah it's a
little too close but yeah we're very
very very close you're one of ten yeah
there's seven
seven
and my i have a sister my brother-in-law
my brother
my mom and their
my little niece and nephew
but they're all in the house right now
yeah oh my god yeah it's just it's just
great but it's it's temporary yeah
but it must be great especially for your
daughter because she's great
i'm great having the cousins around and
we're always together anyway um our
family is very very very close
and uh it's it's it's pretty awesome you
know you don't get to choose your family
right yeah because some family can just
suck sure i i would choose pretty much
every family member i got and i love
them all so much and it's reflective of
my friendships too right yeah yeah um
you're so close with all your old
friends yeah yeah yeah
what um
and and are there so you're gonna be
doing more so do you have to say if it's
whatever but more marvel stuff in in um
yeah there's always marvel with the
marvel world is there's always options
to you know like even the word end game
right with any ending there's always
another beginning um like i think
they're doing a scarlet uh it's called
a black widow movie um which is awesome
um but there's lots of um things that
that can happen and i i don't know what
they are
or that i can tell you anything
you're resting you're resting [ __ ]
faces give it away you're smiling that's
right what is it you got to tell me like
a really weird fan
interaction you must have some and i
know you love the fans and
it's great it must but there's got to be
some
i've done
just a few of those like convention
things yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i've seen some crazy [ __ ] there's
some really weird [ __ ] some of it's most
of it's like really great yeah
appreciative and affectionate
but are there do you have any really
weird ones
um i think the whole thing is weird to
be honest with you yeah in the sense of
because i
i'm just a dude like i yeah i don't know
how people perceive me right i don't
know yeah i'm just a dude from modesto
california so happy i didn't get someone
pregnant when i was 20. yeah i'd still
have a mow it and drive around a trans
am you know but i didn't so i don't i'm
still just that dude i'm a kid from a
small town and
i don't know how people perceive me and
i i don't really care to know of course
right it's hard to it's impossible well
it's also like a slippery slope if you
start investigating that and investing
in that that's right it's like you're
[ __ ] yeah um
but as so from that perspective from
that kid from modesto so it probably
gives affords you like a very uh
almost like an objective point of view
when it comes to fandom and
people dressing up and stuff like
so you show up at those premieres and
they're
people just clamoring to get is it is it
is there a
did do you maintain that that sense of
disconnect or do you enjoy it it's the
opposite very it's a very um
it's more of a real connect you know
i i i like spending time with the fans
especially like at the premieres i mean
yeah i want to talk to the carpet and
people yeah microphones and like i've
done enough of that get out of here i
want to go talk to the fans that really
make all that happen totally and i spend
a lot of time just you know
i look at people in the eye and shake
their hands this is awesome yeah let's
take a photo and i really yeah i spend
the time doing it and there's there's
value in it to me to have to spend the
time of course i mean that's why and
nobody gets that weird you know it might
get grabbed here and there and uh-huh
sometimes
a non-vital organ yeah life could be a
dream
do you text a lot are you a big texter i
you know i
yeah i guess but like one letter yeah
okay
[Laughter]
what do you use about here
here yeah
i wrote a lot more oh good i'm glad that
you're really
paragraph back please
[Laughter]
i wish i had a little bit i gotta borrow
some of that i gotta start doing more
the render text thing here you go when
it comes to render text what's your most
commonly used emoji what's the what's
the one where you what's your emoji k
that you'd write back your go-to
um
just literally
okay
okay
yeah no uh thumbs up smiley face i have
to ask these oh yeah i guess um yeah
maybe thumbs up uh to my business
manager to say it's okay to pay
something okay okay time's up or it's a
finger okay
middle finger yeah don't pay it or you
have to pay but i'm angry about it
exactly
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play what did you
play in school i was i was into soccer
and
uh
wow bowling but it's not a sport
bowling is bowling a sport yeah no
that's where dave was a kid i've been
watching a lot of uh cornhole there's a
cornhole i've seen that on espn or
something like that they're incredible
that's that's a real thing but they all
look like they only drink beer like
they've they've been drinking beer for
seven years they all but they're are
they athletes i don't know
you don't want to lose the cornhole
obviously yeah
all the time i love cornhole yeah but
but are
are you an athlete when you're playing
well yeah you know i suppose
but
you just be very careful yeah maybe yeah
yeah um so bowling or but you would be
yeah if i if i was gonna be in a sport i
yeah i don't know if uh
there's one i'd want to be in i like
watching football uh-huh i don't want to
do that who's your teammate chef nine or
something 1979 from being up uh northern
california that's right um they're
looking okay
yeah yeah yeah garoppolo i think the
we'll probably start picking back up and
getting some victories do you ever go to
games i do
when i can yeah absolutely yeah um if
you have you're on instagram a lot or
you have a huge instagram following yeah
what's that so like social media is is
uh kind of
i know it's like
it's
it's unnecessary it's kind of necessary
yeah evil or you know just kind of
it's kind of junky to be honest with you
yeah um but i don't
really want like to mess with it too
much just enough to kind of output stuff
um
you know
so you don't read stuff or interact yeah
yeah yeah again slippery slopes yeah uh
if you could have one one snack food for
the rest of your life what what would it
be
cookie dough
just cookie dough is that a snack yeah
or is that a meal uh well it depends how
much you eat
the log of it the log of it you know
just allow you to shove it yeah cookie
dough tube that'd be a meal i think
so that's there's my next ques the
answer my next question
favorite meal is a log of cookies
uh
favorite entree what's your uh oh
favorite movie of all time who who
because sammy had so many
ins you know heroes uh i mean that all
those guys from the 70s gene you strike
me as
being really inspired by guys like that
as well yeah yeah i think it's hard hard
to quantify or limit i'd always figure
out like okay if i was going to watch
like i have to look like okay what
movies have i seen more than 30 times
exactly
okay there would be clockwork orange it
would be jungle book
um the animated jungle book and then you
know
e.t if i saw a bunch it's all you know
what yeah what movies have i seen
literally that much or if i if it popped
on tv braveheart popped on tv i'd have
to finish the rest exactly matter where
it started you know yeah ah we were just
talking about that last night i got to
refine that because yeah to pick one
movie and
i took see i'll watch any time in time
there are movies that i'll watch
whenever it's not i i kind of have to
it's like
hanging out with a friend you know um i
i feel that way about the town i know
the town so well but i i have to watch
it's so
[ __ ] good i've seen it once i think
what not yeah it's not once
yeah
that's like um
that's i don't really like to watch it
that's like 19 fewer times than i've
seen it yeah you've only seen it once
yeah it yeah is there a reason
i don't know like so i shot the damn
movie
well i haven't seen tv in 30 years man i
mean i don't watch that's right you
don't have you don't have it you don't
have tv yeah and it's i have tvs just
don't use i don't watch tv
it's also because i i'm like like i said
i'm an actionable kind of i don't like
yeah
i like the output
to sit back and just receive something
so when you're not working when you're
not acting what are you what is that
output well well when's i'm not working
anymore really
um
when's the last time i did work i don't
remember so what so what what
satisfaction i make believe we're living
right yeah
right right so the last time you played
what what when you're not playing what
satisfies that like doing itch you say
you're actionable whatever both i think
growth yeah
yeah growth that happens my own personal
growth yeah
output comes from it um as an artist as
you know there's it's not
like if you're a comic which you are in
my mind right you could do stand up i
don't know if you have done stand-up but
that might be the hardest job on the
planet but what is oh you're getting
laughs back
or whatever exactly i'm not i don't have
that i'm not a painter
yeah right as an actor how do you
well instagram followers there you go
and then with music it's just sort of
auditory yeah so building homes was very
very uh gratifying satisfying to me
because yeah it's a tangible thing
that's why i like gardening i i love
doing something with my hands i love
having something to show for it i love
looking back and seeing a
plant grow there's something really
satisfying about that it's funny i don't
really get that satisfaction from seeing
movies i've done people and i think
about that sometimes should i be more
proud that i've done these this should
that fill me in a way that it doesn't
really because people
there's so many actors who would kill to
be in that position right um
but you but i know what you mean it's
the doing of it that was really i look
back on and think oh that was gratifying
or
or not um
if you could hear something or not it
wasn't
regret
or it was herbie
the magic car
which was also gratifying because
they're great stories uh if you could uh
if you have to live somewhere else would
it be up north
lake tahoe is where i spend most of my
time that's when the resident of nevada
where it's not far from where i'm
originally from oh cool and not because
i can
i can exist there at the elevation when
i was right by a ski resort but was a
big skier um i love the
stars the this i'm surrounded by trees
and cleaning celebrities water by stars
exactly yeah exactly
and then no traffic that's amazing so
the quality of life for me is is so much
better up there and then it's also great
for my family and my daughter
oh yeah you're right on on the lake um
on the top of the the mountain and the
lake's just uh
down the hill so cool yeah um
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive uh whom you've
never met who would they be i never met
it's gonna be dinner too or lunch i
never do that uh brunch
yeah i never i'm glad it's only three
because i've never what do you mean you
don't have dinner with people
socially no i it's like four is good
number okay more than that because and i
get invited to those a lot yeah that's a
point oh
everyone's talking i'm never going to
see you way down at that at the tables
you're out of here this is terrible this
is something else i admire about you i
would imagine that you would have no
trouble just passing on those things oh
yeah yeah
but what am i [ __ ]
[Music]
hey listen jeremy they want you to do
this dinner for the i mean like it's
like a marvel thing yeah yeah do you
have to go
uh
what do you say how many people are at
the table
i just did one
yeah
and if it's more than four you say god
yeah yeah i need that i need some of
that so so i don't think there's i don't
think to answer your question i don't
think there's any names it might be like
um
okay people that are interesting because
i don't want to be disappointed either
if i picked out a few names like oh i'm
saying what a [ __ ] he was
[Laughter]
god lincoln's so selfish i know he keeps
grabbing my food and he's a little
touchy
you know i mean so i wouldn't want to be
disappointed by
somebody i'd love to like to sit down
and have a chat with you sorry i just
have such a clear visual of lincoln
grabbing your junk
jesus abe
[Laughter]
you know you know be cool i think like
to sit down with my dad
when he was if we were the same age oh
yeah yeah that would be cool back to the
future so good uh right right that kind
of vibe yeah like that would be really
cool or interesting to me do you hang
out with your dad a lot yeah my dad and
i are very very close as well cool yeah
that's awesome and same house he's in
you see he's he's not in the same house
he's uh up by my house in tahoe oh he's
got in grass valley with uh my two
little brothers oh that's great yeah um
who is your fantastic task it is who's
your favorite muppet
animal
i do like do you like
because they're such [ __ ] they're
just like [ __ ] it might be like sam
yeah
yeah you know
it's like you and sam being like the
[ __ ] is that yeah
all these people could kiss my whole ass
the town i wouldn't watch the city
exactly who if you could have one
superpower
uh what would if if you give hawkeye for
example uh
a super human skill
oh
you know okay i am asked that all the
time and it's usually in an interview
yeah with somebody in my after nine
hours and was like oh what is that give
me that answer when uh after the day of
the press junket so okay if you've got
godzilla and hawkeye yeah
jason barney i'm like oh my goodness
that's a godzilla wins all the time
godzilla wins
he's like what's your superpower oh yeah
i want the power um
was it to nap
oh the narcissistic yeah so then i just
go to
sleep to know if you wake up and you're
gone
see how amazing the men in black power i
just want to forget this ever happened
exactly ask a good question
yeah that's a dumb question yeah yeah
yeah there's a really funny way for you
to leave i think it's you and scarlett
doing a joke and she gets asked like a
really that guy who's like really like
aggressive and
uh
kind of a thick media guy from like
extra or something he's like he's asking
her about her like
underwear
oh and she's just like what are you
doing yeah no i just want what that's
what i know i mean uh i know yeah that
got really fun yeah yeah i never watch
any of those things just terrible junk
things well i sometimes i like watching
who watches them
i like yeah i like watching awkward
interviews oh yeah yeah that's great i'm
sure i'm in a lot of them and now this
is the only one uh but at the end of the
it's good yeah but i like doing a game
in those junkets where um because you're
right they do get so tedious and like
i like uh
if you're doing it with another person
you say like a phrase that you have to
hit like that's the way the cookie
crumbles so when they're like so who
would win in a fight like hawkeye or
whatever you could be like
well look uh you know hawkeye does have
the bow and arrow and this other guy's
strong look whatever happens that's just
yeah it's really funny that's for next
time
if you could be one age physically for
the rest of your life what would you
pick physically um
i'd say
uh
probably
35
yeah 35.
if you had to be
an animal a non-human animal what what
animal do you
identify with what animal do you do
did you just like
you look at you feel like i could be
that in the next life if i were
reincarnated it'd be awesome to be that
frog that kind of thing yeah wouldn't it
be cool to be there for no um
rich fries
i think i got i do love love hawks um oh
yeah which would be kind of appropriate
but oh yeah except that idea of flight
yes yeah you know jb smoove was on a
couple days ago and he goes i like to be
a i'd like to fly but not he's but i'm
afraid of heights
be like a mosquito or something like
that's right we just pictured him like
hovering like on a segway but without
the segway
it was such a funny image of jb's moves
like just hovering around um uh dogs are
cats
dogs yeah um
uh beetle stones
do i have to make a decision of choice
yeah this is a real beatles yeah okay
but you don't want to expand on that uh
uh do you ever think about your your
i mean this is dark but
how do you want to go out do you ever
think about what else is out there do
you are you
locked into this left you ever think
about oh my all the time yeah yeah star
stars because i love i love this guy i
like to i love talos yeah it's always a
great reminder especially if i have any
sort of stress or things that are
happening they're they're not great in
life it's great to
get out of your own way and just think
about wait there's
you know what am i doing i'm just a
grain of sand on this thing and my
little stupid problems that i
that may have been ruining my life yeah
um just kind of just gives you a little
perspective
with that it is more like in belief
systems and i'm not i studied every
religion growing up but i'm not
religious you weren't raised in any
particular religion
experienced every religion my dad was a
theologist oh wow so i studied every
religion so it just wasn't my thing like
when organized religion isn't my thing
but
i'm sorry for people you know religion's
right and my belief system is just more
energetic and
and things like that that were more it's
more science meets
[Music]
that i have uh i don't fear death yeah
um you don't no i know i'll be buried uh
under a tree i'll be cremated and buried
under a tree to create more life on the
planet right to i already know that and
i'll settle with that it's how do you
not fear death
because i've
really had a great life yeah because of
huh maybe not fearing death you know wow
i'm not trying to be reckless trying to
kill myself
and it's not something i can really
control
you know what do we have control of we
don't control when we die
we do have control of how we perceive
things though
we have control of our bodies or
physical bodies sometimes and you get
older then you can't even do that but we
do have control of our perception and um
that is
to me the collection to any sort of
happiness in life and being solid with
yourself wow that is so and
problem-solving that's great for
problem-solving skills you know which
you know i think people
we all need yeah yeah yeah are you
instilling anything uh how how do you
treat that subject with your daughter
what do you say to her about has that
come up any any of those big things come
up
um it's it's more done in actually being
actionable in it being very consistent
and constant in her life yeah the first
seven years of development or the most
important and affecting for for any
human being
and especially girls because they're um
exceptionally more smart in a tune uh
in their brains than boys are boys are
quite dumb as [ __ ]
um typically but especially for a young
girl
before uh besides a father to a young
girl as well that the connection between
their con is is uh is very very
important and lasting and then the seven
to 14 14 21 21 to 28 on the last last
quadrant of human development real human
development yeah do you see
what
of you do you see in her
um quite a bit actually quite quite a
bit also physically we
have pictures of us the same age it's
she looks like your mom
she's got she's got a a scowl she's got
a little bit less all right i got a
little bit less for my mom and she got a
little bit less for me but she's got to
go [ __ ] yourself oh yeah okay and i like
that yeah and she has a shirt that'll
serve her well she has a lot okay i
don't have to worry about my daughter i
don't worry about you son trying to date
my daughter yeah yeah you with your open
eager let's do it face
[Laughter]
um
[ __ ] man so so under the tree do you
want anything on the tree do you want
like a um any sort of epitaph on the
tree nope just you want your family to
know where the tree is
that'd be probably pretty cool yeah
don't chop it down
[Laughter]
don't piss on it exactly
um [ __ ] man well uh
you know i i am one of the handful of of
people who uh have not seen endgame and
i and i
and i know you need all the advertising
so i i want to encourage people to go
see that but what what should they see
next what should they do next um i don't
know whatever they want to get some
lunch
be good to yourself yeah be thoughtful
of others buddy i i can't thank you
enough for doing this you didn't have to
i mean for you to do this was was really
cool i'm glad it's great to see you but
you said you were in new york like [ __ ]
off ain't going to new york yeah it
doesn't work for my daughter you're
right but you know this is just amazing
usually we do this in tahoe so yeah i'm
sorry that didn't work i'll be
co-hosting with you okay you're filling
in yeah thanks buddy this is [ __ ] fun
it's good to see you and i'm so proud of
you i'm so happy for you uh and
everything that's going on in the last
10 years yeah uh okay and everyone
please go see avengers
please it's come on we gotta help
help the box office all right thanks man
so
that happened
that happened that happened anyway that
did happen that happened my very first
impression
when i when i was listening to the
interview was
god does he have a beautiful speaking
voice
yeah it's it's it's mellifluous
it's beautiful and it's so smooth and
rich
isn't it mm-hmm nothing against you you
have a beautiful voice
it's it you have a great voice but
there's something so uh
full-bodied like if he if his voice was
coffee it would be a full body dark
roast
it was a beautiful speaking voice it
makes sense that he has such a great
singing voice it's the kind of voice
that demands you listen to it which i
think is what makes him such a great
and powerful
actor he said something like if i didn't
have the life i have now if i hadn't
gone down this road
i very well could be a guy
living in modesto having impregnated my
girlfriend when i was 20. he said
something like a mullet
i do too because it's it's funny he he
seems like that kind of guy yeah who
just happens to have
these extraordinary extraordinary
abilities
of these artistic abilities
singing and dancing
that's why he's so rare i think that's
why he's
if you name these other big movie stars
that we have now tom cruise and hugh
jackman and uh will smith
there's something kind of polished about
all of them and there's something
unlike them he's got this rough around
the edges kind of regular
yeah
guy yeah that's why he's so convincing
at playing those part i mean in the town
he plays he's so convincing at being
a i hate to use the word regular the
term regular joe or like just like a a
a blue collared normal guy he um because
you're right
and i've heard a lot of actors say
versions of that they'll try to create
this narrative about
their success that um or their their
acting success uh i
mistakenly used that term with jeremy
and he was right he kind of called me
out and he was like i don't measure
success that way there must be some
element of even if it's just like
security now i'm okay when he was
talking about
fear i thought it was interesting and
how he said that you know he studied
psychology and he
worked on something he was afraid of
every day for 10 years and and he
strikes me now as someone and i'm sure
he does
fear things and he he has his issues but
he he seems like he doesn't
really fear much
that's really appealing i think that's a
big reason why he is such an appealing
person to watch i wonder if that will
come across in just listening to it
listening to the interview i wonder so i
should stress that when i was asking him
these questions and he was answering
he seemed so earnest i mean like he
didn't flinch
he wasn't shifting around at all there's
something so present and grounded and
truthful about him you you asked him if
he was afraid to die and he said no and
you couldn't believe it
i know i couldn't either i know but i i
believe he's not i do too it's just so
hard for me to relate to that i feel so
we're just such different people i know
such an understatement yeah but you are
but i think he's different than most
people i think most i would i would
guess that most people have some
on a scale of one to ten have some
degree of fear about something like that
of dying yeah and the fact that he was
like no i'm not afraid of that i don't
want to do it now but i'm not afraid of
it he is like our steve mcqueen or gene
hackman he there's something so steely
and
secure about him you know so so
confident he also may have broken
accidentally massive news on this
podcast
at one point he says under his breath
about about hawkeye
there's there's gonna be
more is that your jeremy renner
impression no no
there's going to be uh more
you do hesitate too i know i can't do i
can't do it
i can't believe i even tried i'm so
ashamed that i tried so arrogant to even
try to run an impression um
he does have a beautiful voice you asked
him about his legacy and he said he
gives zero [ __ ] about perception which
not only do i believe that but i think i
also think that really sums him up that
he that he would say oh my legacy my
perception i don't know i don't give a
[ __ ] about that seems to inform
everything about him that he's not
concerned with what people think of him
and and people who are really cool and
confident
are not concerned what people think
exactly and that's what makes them cool
and confident we've talked about this
before but if you watch nerds like i
think i think that a defining
characteristic of nerdy behavior is
somebody who's just hyper aware of how
they're standing yeah they're talking
jeremy is whatever the opposite of a
nerd is
i loved his uh dinner when he answered
that he said he said what
who what three people would you have
dinner with and he was like ah it's got
to be dinner huh
but i totally agree with them about
those big dinners those 14-person
dinners where what's the point
first of all it's really annoying to
figure out the check at the end but you
can't talk to the person who's on the
other end you know it's funny you know
it's true but unlike jeremy i don't have
the balls to say uh i can't go to this
thing that i don't want to go to i would
end up going because i feel bad i feel
guilty but he has no trouble passing on
a dinner especially when you get seated
near somebody that you don't really know
and you get it's you have to cross talk
uh i loved when you talked about he
didn't miss a beat when you asked him
whose favorite muppet is animal oh that
was that because he is an animal is he's
a real doer and i think jeremy is i mean
he's he's not animal but there's
something very uh he's a doer yeah you
know and he doesn't watch he talks about
not watching tv and and being uh
consuming things he does things god i so
admire that i do too and that's also one
of the things i really like about doing
this podcast in general is you hear from
people who have who have
characteristics and qualities that you
admire that you don't have yeah and
there's something aspirational about
that specific quality i think for me
when you find yourself getting lazy and
passive and sitting back and and
consuming too much there's something
really it's it's i think it's such a
good lesson yeah especially for kids
especially for his fans totally
get out there and do [ __ ] especially for
kids in this generation not the vhs kids
like you at the end of
your interview you said like you say to
all the guests a version of this so what
should people
uh see you in next like what should
people watch and his answer was
something to the effect of
i don't care do whatever you want i
don't give a [ __ ] i felt like such a
sellout
nerdy i just felt so like
disgusting oh come on i did i mean like
that
my values system was all off that
there's something about him that he has
kind of figured it out i'm not i'm not i
don't want to like
over
praise him or sell him to too
hard but see i'm sure you have qualities
that he admires i'm sure it works both
ways he did say to you i don't know
maybe maybe not
you're alvin
[Laughter]
[Music]
god damn it why do i be hawkeye i wish i
could have been alvin
at least theodore i love i love that he
doesn't care what people see him in eggs
i don't do whatever you want and it's
such it's classic runner he does give
zero [ __ ] oh this is what i was
thinking too i wonder how much of it has
to do with our physical appearance too
we talk about how i have like a more
open and i relied on that as a kid i was
really small brenner was athletic and he
had this
[ __ ] resting face yeah not [ __ ]
[Laughter]
like just like an arrow through your
neck all of a sudden
um
how's that for [ __ ] that's my runner
that's uh that's you're pushing pushing
too much um so that i really enjoyed
that yeah um i hope you guys did too i
hope you learned as much as we did about
how to behave and and how disappointed
we are with ourselves and i hope you're
as disappointed in yourself as we are
and with ourselves and thanks for
listening next week's episode is going
to be a live interview i did with the
amazing neil brennan he's a comedian he
co-created the legendary chappelle show
and co-wrote half-baked
it was so fun doing the interview in a
room filled with
people life could be a dream
[Music]
if you want to hear my interview episode
with neil a week early ad free you can
listen to next week's episode right now
by signing up for wondering plus at
wondery.com
plus that's w-o-n-d-e-r-y
dot com slash p-l-u-s and hopefully
you'll enjoy the voice memo at the end
of this episode
uh but if but if you don't want to hear
it as jeremy would say i don't care
either way do whatever you want thanks
for listening to life is short if you
enjoyed the show
maybe you want to give us a five star
review that would help us out a lot and
it would ensure that the show keep going
tell your friends to subscribe we're
available on apple podcast spotify
google podcasts and every major
listening app as well as onedrive.com
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by christian long and
megan monaco michelle lanz is our senior
producer and it's executive produced by
marshall louis and ernan lopez for
wondering
can you make the argument that his the
real
uh personality between clark and
superman like this is his true self and
superman is like an act i was thinking
that but no because when he was born in
uh
krypton
used to pay me before he gets sent away
he was raised by nerdy american parents
yeah so they should have so
uh nurture over nature then they
actually raised him to be a nerd they
changed him to be a nerd they did i
think he
so why when he goes but how about when
he goes back to the fortress of solitude
and he's like he's like oh [ __ ] it's my
dad he's not like what are these
crystals he like that's true he has
confidence
that's true so where did he get that
from
where he but that's true so that's just
how he naturally is
who's the real personality narcan
or superman that's the question could it
be both what if he's schizophrenic like
is that maybe that's how it seems
that shouldn't that behavior that
shouldn't be like that his dad
should be like seen as troubled
he's also the son of like a famous
general his dad was like bet it was like
his dad didn't raise him he said to me i
know i know but i'm saying he may
genetically have this
nature over it's like this this superman
clark debate is very similar to the
nature of our nursery yeah that's true
it's like if you if you're a nurturer
over nature person
you can easily make the argument that
it's real yeah so when he's being raised
by these nerves yeah but yeah that
doesn't make any sense when he's being
superman you never see a glimpse of like
you don't see clark kentucky maybe it's
a flaw in the performance then and or in
the writing
like i wonder if whoever wrote this had
this conversation in mind if they
thought like
this is who he really is they never
address that they never address it
that's amazing who's the real guy yeah
which one's the act maybe they do they
i've always assumed that clark kent was
the act because he's just like cool
handsome because he knows what you're
capable of and like you know what it is
i think it's superficial of me because i
always assume that someone who looked
that good that handsome and like strong
could it couldn't be a nerd so that must
be the oh interesting you know yeah but
haven't you known big like kind of
strapping nerds
uh you know alex flying alex cline's a
strapping nerd yes
that's a good name for a band
you